well
number 85 not tyler eifert
there he is walking into practice trey
burton points out someone tell my guy he
doesn't need to put his gloves on
probably for another 30 to 45 minutes
and then there's the hand the aggressive
handshake pulling him in not quite like
we've seen others do it but
tim too but trey burton by the way
available
if anyone's looking for a tight end a
real tight end a tight end who threw a
touchdown pass in the super bowl
something tim tebow's never done and
never will do philly special was thrown
by trey burton to nick foles so uh but
once once that spot's taken
no one else out there who may be more
worthy of that spot has a chance to get
it just saying it's a zero-sum game and
spot number 90 on the roster goes to tim
tebow shireen
you haven't been on during the height of
all of this sims and i have been uh
chiming in on a daily basis about mr
tebow your reaction
to tebow back in the nfl nine years
after he last played in a regular season
game
i'm not bothered a bit by it mike i get
it like i went on the jaguars flagship
radio station yesterday they're hyped
about this i mean this is a guy who grew
up in jacksonville who went to the
university of florida who won a national
championship there who won the heisman
trophy there i mean this city is excited
they want to see what he can do at tight
end now the rest of us know the truth
he has no chance to make this roster do
i think he's going to be on the practice
squad yeah because his coach is urban
meyer and that's the reason he's on this
roster to begin with i don't think he's
going to make their roster and in fact i
would put his odds at zero percent to
make their roster but i do think he'll
end up on the practice squad and i also
think that it's an a no risk
challenge for for the jaguars to convert
this guy to tied in a position he's
never played i don't think he can do it
i don't think he's logan thomas early in
his career and look at how long it took
logan thomas to become a really good
tight end and i think logan thomas is a
really good tight end i don't know if he
has the body to become a tight end in
the nfl to begin with and it's been so
long since he's played in the nfl but
i'm unbothered by this and i get why
they did it they're probably going to
sell quite a few jerseys and if he does
end up making the roster just because
he's tim tebow which frankly i just gave
it 0
chance to happen but i guess it could
happen if urban meyer just wants tim
tebow on its team somehow but i think
he's more likely to make the practice
squad and be there and and kind of be in
a leadership role in the locker room
sort of i don't know can you be in a
leadership role as a practice squad
player
maybe not but
he knows what urban meyer is about and
urban meyer knows him quite well i get
why he's on their roster i get why
they're trying to do what they're trying
to do
i think he has no chance to ever play a
game in the nfl
if we make these decisions about tim
tebow based solely on merit he's got no
chance to make the regular season roster
but if we make these decisions about tim
tebow based solely on merit he wouldn't
be on the roster right now so
that
that question of merit and worth and
value and
what he does or doesn't deserve that
that's going to be ultimately determined
by one person
this could be determined by urban meyer
and despite the
growth the spread the embrace of
analytics at the end of the day
coach decides
especially in jacksonville some cities
gm decides
jacksonville coach decides who's going
to be there who's not going to be there
my theory has been shireen he will be on
the practice squad he will be called up
because two players each week can be
called up from the practice squad
and
i think after you do it the second time
you actually have to release them to get
them back onto the roster well it's not
like there's anyone else nobody's
picking him up that's going to pick him
up even after the trade deadline when
eva and he's not even a vested veteran
he'd go through waivers if he got cut
after that first week he's got three
credited seasons no one's going to claim
him on waivers if he's dropped down from
the active roster after week one they're
going to find a way to get him in
uniform they're going to find a way to
get him on the field and
here's
here's my
issue with it
don't try to make us think it's
something other than what it is
and i know they're not going to come out
and say
this is just a sideshow this is just a
gimmick this is a minor league baseball
slow wednesday night promotion this is a
way to get attention this is a way to
sell jerseys this is a way to build
interest that's all it is this isn't
about football because if you say that
you undermine the stuff you're actually
trying to do so leave it to people like
us
to peel back the curtain for the jaguars
and explain exactly what it is it's a
business move
it's not about football
and that's their prerogative
but my point is
you know there's still
millions of people out there who don't
understand the nuances
and look at it and think it is about
football and it's some great disney
movie the seeds of which are being
planted hell tebow's life's already a
disney movie this would be the sequel
tim comes out of retirement it could be
like ernest ernest goes to camp ernest
does this ernest plays for the jaguars
ernest plays baseball i
do you remember ernest
do you please tell me you remember
earnest please tell me they're not going
to remember
who was ernest
er you don't remember who ernest is
ernest is a guy who would jim varney
jim varney
nothing vern no are you doing vern he'd
get in the camera he called the camera
vern
oh please share you make me sad you're
older than me you should know
you should know who ernest is by three
months
anyway and i'm catching you soon i'm
catching you soon um
but uh but anyway my point is
we know what it is
we we know what it is and yeah and and
who knows maybe some of the people who
are going to buy the tebow jersey know
deep down what it is just like people
know wrestling's fake now and they're
okay with it but look at the dip look at
the difference look at the difference
and this is just an example
when they
ended the draft and they signed
undrafted free agents guys who were good
enough to be in the mix but but you know
it's a seven round draft
there's the six guys they signed that's
all we got name rank and serial number
for those six guys then here comes
guy number 90 on the roster and he gets
this multi-paragraph release that that
dusts off
his
accomplishments as a quarterback with
the denver broncos when he threw a
touchdown pass to demaryius thomas to
beat the steelers in a wild card playoff
game that shows you what this is and
that's okay i'm not saying
i the the only the only thing
that substantively bothers me is
you are taking away someone else's
chance there is somebody else out there
more deserving of the chance to be guy
number 90 on the roster like trey burton
for example there are others out there
more deserving who have more merit if
this truly is a meritocracy this
shouldn't be happening there's a point
though where
merit takes a back seat to money
and and that that's why we are where we
are plain and simple
well
yeah
and you talked about it's not about
football i would argue that it's a
little bit about football because tim
tebow knows urban meyer as well as any
player ever has and ever will and what's
that have to do with getting him on the
field and having the ball bounce off his
head though
well i don't think it's getting him on
the field but i think in the locker room
he can make a difference mike and i
don't know maybe again maybe they don't
listen to a prac squad player but this
is a guy who won a heisman trophy right
and and it is a guy who who's done some
great things in college uh and has been
on tv people know who tim tebow is you
know they may not know those guys on
that list of free agents other than
moses from alabama everybody knows he
was the captain on that defense at
alabama but you know they don't know a
lot of those guys they know tim tebow
everybody knows tim tebow that's what
we're talking about tim tebow because
everybody knows tim tebow so he can get
across some of urban meyer's ideas i
think in the locker room perhaps if if
guys are willing to listen to him and
maybe it's just a matter of working hard
i don't know he did play some special
teams for the jets maybe he does get on
the field as a special teams player
right you know i didn't even thought of
him calling him up and and doing special
teams for the jaguars this season i just
thought he's never going to play a game
for the jaguars and i still find it hard
to believe that he'll be on the field
this year i do think he'll be in the
locker room i don't know that he'll be
on the field for him can you it would be
a bigger deal to me mike him taking the
90th spot on the off season roster it
would be a bigger
deal to me if he's taking one of those
spots on game day
and maybe not contributing like he
should be contributing as one of your
game day players does that make sense
yeah look i i see this going one of two
ways
one way is it's it just clearly doesn't
work
and he retires
from football he's not going to get the
unceremonious bring your playbook to see
the coach you've been cut
he's going to he's going to have
the conversation urban's going to come
to him and say hey tim you know i love
you and i what inspiration you've been
it's been great to have you here but you
know i think you know where this is and
i think we know where this is and we're
going to give you a chance you know i
think the right thing for you to do is
just go out with your head held high and
you proved everybody wrong just the mere
fact that you were here
is a major accomplishment that kind of
thing and then he walks away and and the
longer it goes without him walking away
the more likely he's going to find his
way onto the team even if it is practice
squad and then called up and then
dressed out on game day and you know you
make a good point
unless he somehow gets his way to the
top of the tight end depth chart he is
going to be a 34 year old special teamer
for the jacksonville jaguars and from
his perspective maybe he'd be happy
doing that
but
uh uh and and i i really don't know what
the impact of tim tebow in the locker
room is going to be
are they going to roll their eyes at him
what are they gonna do or once they meet
him remember remember the who was the
guy was it tom brennaman five minutes
with tim tebow changes your life
remember that comment
i i mean maybe he does truly have this
magnetic personality and to the extent
that there are any cynics or hard-boiled
long-term veterans in their mid-30s as
old or older than tim tebow and they
kind of sneer at him and then he's
really nice to them
are they gonna are they gonna are they
gonna change are they to yield so
i i don't know but i do know this i do
know this
shireen i know that you want to buy a
kellenbond jersey to supplant your roger
staubach jersey and i support that you
also could buy a tim tebow jersey to
supplant both of them because it wasn't
more than an hour or so
after tim tebow officially joined the
jaguars that you could go to the jaguars
online shop and there it was
as prominent
as trevor lawrence as prominent as
travis atn
initially it was zero they did change it
to 85. that zero looks odd but there he
is he's crowding out trevor lawrence are
you kidding me shouldn't trevor lawrence
be in the foreground of that are you
kidding me
but tebow you can you can get the jersey
and even though 85 is the number that
comes out now if you look at the fine
print
the jersey will be sent
after his official number is selected in
other words after they trade or cut
gardner minshew and reassign 15 to tim
tebow that's when you'll get your jersey
and and
i i i my understanding is the jaguars
don't want any part of that
maybe the jaguars don't want any part of
that the jaguars don't want to make this
about go buy jerseys go buy jerseys this
is fanatics exercising their prerogative
anyone on the team they can do this they
can hype this they control it well the
jaguars may not want it
but the jaguars
necessarily understand
you pull the pin on this grenade
you're getting it you're getting it you
can't control it yeah you can say please
don't do it they're still going to do it
because fanatics is there to maximize
the revenue that they generate on behalf
of the nfl and if you're selling jaguars
jerseys
tim tebow right now is going to maximize
that revenue so uh look we'll see what
happens i i i don't have any
animosity toward the jaguars or to him i
feel bad for trey burton or whoever else
should have that spot on the roster
and
i i i just it
we know what they're doing
and
i i just i want to make sure that the
casual observer out there
understands what this is and what this
isn't this isn't a disney movie
this is something that they want us to
think could be a disney movie it's not
this guy has no business being on an nfl
roster at this point and the only reason
he is shireen is because his college
coach is in position to say come join my
roster
well no question about that if it wasn't
for meyer he wouldn't be there we all
know that let me ask you this mike do
you think there's any is there any way
that he can help trevor lawrence in that
i mean he's been through a lot of the
things that trevor lawrence is going to
go through i mean becoming a pro and all
the studying and everything you have to
do to become an nfl quarterback now we
know he wasn't as successful nfl
quarterback but he went through all
those things can he help trevor lawrence
in that way in any kind of way
i i i you know i i can envision a
situation where trevor lawrence is out
throwing the ball and tim tebow comes
out and he says hey let me throw the
football and he throws it he says see
what i just did never do that that would
help trevor lawrence other than that i
don't think he's going to help
i really reset you forced me you forced
me to say that um no i
and hey tebow package apparently they're
already talking about it tebow package
philly special put him on the field let
him throw a pass we saw the over unders
for receiving yards and receiving
touchdowns we need over unders for
passing touchdown
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports